when Christopher Nolan announced that
he'd be tackling the controversial topic
of America's most horrifying scientific
advancements we're pretty sure no one
expected it was going to involve so much
nudity those heading to the theater this
weekend to see the historical epic
Oppenheimer should be prepared to see a
lot of actors Killian Murphy and
Florence Pugh especially if they plan on
seeing it on a massive iMac screen as
Nolan suggests the film sees Nolan
directing his first sex scenes and all
of them involving Murphy and Pew's
real-life characters though they are
handled and arguably tasteful ways one
seems to stand out to audiences for how
squeamish it makes them a bizarrely
nightmarish moment sees J Robert
Oppenheimer in his on-again off-again
lover Gene tatlock engaged in an
extended bully nude sex scene in the
middle of the former spateful aec
Security hearing the sequence which
occurs around halfway through the film's
run time will likely surprise many
audience members and even reportedly
elicited scattered laughter at preview
screens happening isn't it when you
understand how the graphic scene is
presented however it's not hard to
imagine why during one of the film's
many flashes to oppenheimer's Security
hearing a clever camera movement sees a
physical just go from Fully Dressed to
butt naked in the middle of a government
building of course meant to be
metaphorical oppenheimer's starkness
receives little contextual build up or
warning surprising audiences in a way
not dissimilar to a jump scare another
cut brings gene tatlock into the scene
with almost as much surprise mounting
Oppenheimer and staring pointedly into
the eyes of his horrified on-looking
wife Kitty played by Emily Blunt the
fact that Murphy maintains his calm
detached demeanor throughout the scene
and continues to deliver cold testimony
with someone writhing on top of him only
drives home how uncomfortable the scene
is for some in the defense of those
audience members who catch the giggles
during what will surely go down as one
of Cinema's strangest sex scenes the
presentation is admittedly and
intentionally shocking that's the whole
point Oppenheimer has been described by
Nolan as a horror movie while it
certainly lives up to the genre in its
existential exploration of nuclear power
this tone also extends to its most
intimate moments it wasn't too long ago
that the weekend was attempting to
defend some similarly uncomfortable sex
scenes in HBO's The Idol by saying they
were supposed to be troubling though
this explanation rank Falls from for the
clumsily exploitative series a
comparable justification could fit this
moment in Oppenheimer the horror of the
sex scene in the Security hearing is not
the act itself but that it's being
painted in the mind of the woman
oppenheimer's cheated on from the way
the scene is framed and especially with
Gene tatlock's eye contact it's pretty
obviously being shown from Kitty's
subjective perspective oppenheimer's
approach of laying himself bare to the
committee may be good for his case but
it's absolutely devastating to Kitty in
a way that's perfectly captured by her
and a room full of strangers watching
the man she trusted having sex with
someone else it's a precise visual
translation of a unique abstract feeling
she's tormented by at that moment a
total theft to privacy autonomy and
dignity nobody knows what you believe
do you if the sex scenes in Oppenheimer
made you uncomfortable perhaps so much
that you let Lucid giggle or two that's
absolutely fine but it may be worth
examining if it was actually the nudity
or sex that caused the uneasiness or
what those scenes said about the
complicated man at the center of it all
foreign